-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
-Thank you.
-This is interesting.
It's your first time
sitting here.
-I've never sat on this couch.
-No, but you performed.
-It's comfy, yeah.
-It is comfy.
-Yeah, very nice.
-I'm so happy to see you
and you talk to you.
-Me too.
-Last time I saw you were --
it was a few months ago.
You performed "Skinny Dipping."
-Yes.
-Which was one of
my all-time jams.
I love that song.
-You talked about it
longer than I did.
-I was obsessed.
-And I wrote it, yeah.
-I'm obsessed with that song.
-Thank you.
-I love it so much.
I love the -- I love
the conversation of it,
-The looseness of it.
-The first verse.
-That first verse, for me,
was the one I go, like,
"What is this song?"
-Yeah.
-'Cause it kind of is like --
almost like, it sets the stage.
It was almost like Paul Simony.
Can I play a little bit?
-Oh, you have it on lock, yeah.
♪ It'll be Wednesday ♪
♪ I'll be going
to this coffee shop ♪
♪ Hear the barista call an
oatmilk latte in your name ♪
♪ And I look up from my phone ♪
♪ And think there's no chance
it's you, but it is ♪
♪ You'll say hi ♪
-All right, that's good.
Say, "Hi. How are you?"
Yeah, I love that.
All right, we can stop.
But that's --
Dude, I love how --
[ Applause ]
I go, "What is this song?"
It felt like I was having
a conversation with someone.
I loved it so much.
-That's the point.
And it's supposed
to feel a little awkward.
'Cause, like, when you have
those, like, encounters
where you run into people
unexpectedly,
and it's the worst
thing in the world
but also the best
'cause it's life, you know?
It's really beautiful.
-And then you miss
the good times and all --
It turns into
the most beautiful song.
-Thanks.
-I love that.
You also --
You confirmed that an album
is coming out this year.
-Yes.
-But you haven't released
any details at all.
-I, actually -- It's funny.
Because I've hidden
the album name somewhere in work
that I've put out
over the last year,
but my fans
haven't found it yet.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
They haven't found it yet.
So...
-That's the new thing
people are doing.
They, like -- you Easter egg
different things.
And so, someone --
it's out there,
the name of the album.
-It is.
-Hmm. Does it have anything
to do with --
You sent me something,
a secret file yesterday,
that I had to delete.
And it deleted after --
-Oh, I sent that to you?
-Yeah.
-Can you imagine?
I, like, didn't mean
to send it to you?
-Yeah.
-Oh, no, yeah, I did.
And that would be
my new song...
-Yes.
-...called...
-Can I say what it's called?
-Yeah.
[ Drumroll ]
-"Fast Times"?
-It's called "Fast Times." Yeah.
-I didn't know
if I could say it.
I'm like --
I'm living in a world where --
-I would so prefer you say it.
-I'm living in a world
where I'm afraid to say
what's gonna happen on
"This Is Us."
-I am, too.
-I don't know
what's gonna happen.
All of these Marvel movies.
-Oh, yeah.
-I don't know if I can
talk about your new song.
-Yeah.
-"Fast Times," I love it.
-Thank you.
-Thank you for sending it to me.
-Thank you. You liked it?
-I loved it.
As soon as I was done,
I wanted to hear it again.
And -- no.
-That's a good sign, yeah.
-No, it's gone.
It left.
-Oh!
Oh, you could only listen once?
-Yeah, it deleted itself.
-Oh, I love my team.
-Are there hidden things
in that song?
-You know, it's kind of funny.
I feel like it's something
that -- a few artists do it.
And I think I just really
have had an amazing relationship
with my fans over the years,
and they love being detectives.
So, I like playing into it.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and then you can find
the name of my album,
and you can,
you know, announce it.
'Cause it's out there.
-All right, I'm gonna find it.
-Yeah, that's your homework.
-All right, that's my homework.
I'm gonna do it, yeah.
-Okay.
-Do you record most of it
in New York?
-I did.
I kind of moved to New York
in hopes of finishing the record
just because, you know, like,
you do that thing
when you're 20,
and you're like,
"I have to move to New York."
-Of course.
-So I did it.
And when I was here --
Obviously, the energy is just so
different from anywhere else.
I grew up on the East Coast,
but New York
is a different beast.
And there was one night
in particular --
And this is how, like,
a song came to be.
I was on my fire escape,
and my friend had a harmonica.
And so I went out
and started playing harmonica,
which I can't do very well.
And there were was a lot of
drunk men down on the streets.
And they were like,
"Play us Billy Joel!"
And I was like,
"I can't do that."
I don't -- I'm not that good.
-They were asking for requests?
-Yeah, song requests.
And --
-Billy Joel.
-Yeah, which is, you know --
-Famous harmonica player --
-Exactly.
-Billy Joel, yeah.
-I was like,
"I am not Billy Joel."
-Yeah, you don't have
a piano here but --
-No, my friend came out
with his guitar, and we were --
we grew, like,
a little audience for the night.
It was really fun.
-That is so New York.
-It was so sweet, yeah.
-That is exactly what you do.
-Yeah.
-And how long
did the concert last?
-You know, we had two --
what do they call them?
Stranglers?
Like, not "stranglers."
Oh, my God, that's terrible.
Stragglers!
-Stragglers.
-Who knows, who knows?
It's New York.
They could have been stranglers.
[ Laughter ]
We don't know.
You got to be careful.
Sabrina, it's your first time
in New York.
-My first time on your show,
too, obviously.
-Yeah, yeah.
No, they -- yeah.
They could've been stranglers,
yeah.
So, I'm glad you're up
on the fire escape.
-Yeah, yeah. I was up.
-Away from the stranglers, yeah.
Can we talk about "Emergency"?
-Yes.
-This is giant.
It's gonna premiere at Sundance.
-Yeah.
-Sundance Film Festival
is major.
-Yeah, I --
It's kind of crazy saying it.
It's an amazing film.
It's based on a short film
that won at Sundance last year.
And, basically, it's like
a dark comedy thriller,
but it touches on, you know,
just the fear
in our communities,
especially with young people of
color regarding the police.
And, yeah, it's premiering
at the end of the month,
and I'm so excited
for people to see it.
-And this year, it's gonna be
also virtual, as well.
So, January 20th,
look out for "Emergency."
Thank you so much for coming on.
-Thank you.
-And if you dropped
any Easter eggs --
I don't know if you did --
-Can you imagine, like,
throughout this interview,
I just said things?
-Yeah.
We don't even know.
[ Laughter ]
All right?
Get ready for it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
Sabrina Carpenter, "Emergency,"
will premiere
at the Sundance Film Festival
on January 20th.